we're on the road
through lebanon's becca valley on a
quest to find what some believe
is a solution in part at least to this
country's economic crisis
cannabis wow it's everywhere
this is the village of yamune tucked
into the valley near syria's border
and this is the village mayor you know
everyone around here
yeah sure a celebrity in these parts
and a man who is convinced the crop here
has the power to help
change lebanon's fortunes it will be
good for most of the people in vicar
and for the economy of lebanon
but here's the thing all this is illegal
at the moment it's an industry that
survives
underground through a combination of
blind eyes backhanders and sometimes
guns and if the government they will
come
to destroy the fields the people all
with their guns against the government
okay so it's kind of like they have it's
like the wild west
the medicinal benefits of cannabis when
prescribed by a doctor
are proven
but the mayor says it is much more than
that so it stretches all the way
all the way over here yeah that is one
of the fields
you have too many fields let's walk
through yeah
you can get the best thread in making
clothes
yet you can get the best rope out of it
you can get
the silly loads of out of it you can get
the best
papers out of it you can get
as i'm telling you more than 40
substances you can get
the climate here is perfect for
marijuana and because it's a weed
it takes little looking after by the
time the harvest comes in september the
plant will be at this height
right across the valley and you know
when you talk to locals
they really do believe that if the
government would listen they could help
to fix lebanon's economy
the lebanese president has signed an
order paving the way for a change in the
legislation but for the moment it's
confused
potentially legalizing a different plant
in the cannabis family
and it means that anyone involved in its
illegal production at the moment
is banned from growing it in the future
back down the road in beirut the
government has literally been telling
people to become more self-sufficient to
rely less on exports
and to boost the agriculture sector
the economy minister is at the centre of
efforts to turn this country around
so what does he make of the mass
production of cannabis
it is one piece of a whole economic plan
if lebanon doesn't go from a grantee
economy
to a productive economy in agriculture
in agro-industry
in industry and in knowledge economy
we will not get out of the crisis who
are in
after morocco in afghanistan lebanon is
already the world's third largest
producer
of marijuana resin but it is all illegal
for now if production was allowed
if it was regulated and if taxes were
applied the view from this valley
is that the opportunities are golden
mark stone sky news
in lebanon's becca valley